[Música]
y
tanto el izquierdista gustavo petro como
el populista rodolfo hernández ya
ejerció su derecho al voto en la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
colombianas
fernández se mantuvo en silencio ante la
prensa mientras que petro denunció
presuntos intentos sistemáticos por
anular votos y pidió a la ciudadanía
revisar con atención los tarjetones
tenemos informes desde colombia
en francia va concluyendo la jornada en
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
legislativas
apenas un 38% del electorado ha acudido
a este llamado según el más reciente
informe del ministerio del interior el
presidente manuel macro no quiere
defender su mayoría absoluta en el
legislativo frente a la alianza nubes de
izquierda
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr celesc
y continúa su visita en el sur del país
y afirmó que no entregarán a nadie esta
región clave mientras tanto las fuerzas
rusas atacaron la ciudad de jarque en
las últimas horas quien denuncia que
moscú está reforzando su ofensiva sobre
esta urbe mientras que el secretario
general de la otan advierte que la
guerra puede extenderse por años tenemos
reporte de ucrania
actualizamos las noticias en la pantalla
de france 24 gracias por continuar con
nosotros yo soy juan pupiales se cumplen
las primeras horas en colombia de la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales 39 millones de personas
están llamadas a las urnas con el
izquierdista gustavo petro y el
populista rodolfo hernández como
candidatos ambos ya acudieron a las
urnas
hernández lo hizo primero en bucaramanga
su principal bastión electoral no
ofreció ni una sola declaración a la
prensa petro por su parte otto en bogotá
donde esperará los resultados ofreció
declaraciones tras emitir su voto en las
que denunció un supuesto intento
sistemático de anular sufragios por lo
que pidió a sus seguidores prestar
particular atención a los tarjetones
quien también ya ejerció su derecho fue
el presidente iván duque quien hizo un
llamado a confiar en las instituciones y
resultados escuchemos
y hoy tenemos que ir todos los
colombianos a las urnas sin miedos sin
intimidaciones sin prejuicios sin sesgos
a elegir al próximo presidente de la
república esto tiene que ser una fiesta
de la democracia con confianza en las
instituciones y con plena confianza en
el veredicto del pueblo colombiano
vamos ahora a bucaramanga con nuestra
compañera daniela blandón daniela se
encuentra en la ciudad de vela de la que
fue alcalde rodolfo hernández él va a
recibir ahí los resultados tal y como ya
hizo en la primera vuelta daniela usted
se encuentra en una ciudad que le ha
demostrado su apoyo a rodolfo hernández
cual es el sentir en esta ciudad
estamos en la universidad cooperativa de
colombia muy muy pocas cuadras del
colegio de santander que fue en donde
justamente esta mañana muy a las 8 de la
mañana el candidato de 77 años rodolfo
hernández depositó su voto y fue
recibido con una gran ovación por parte
de sus simpatizantes y es que en esta
ciudad de bucaramanga que es la capital
del departamento de santander él fue
alcalde entre el 2016 y 2019 y tuvo una
popularidad de más del 80 por ciento a
su salida yo me encuentro justamente con
uno de sus seguidores su nombre por
favor y por qué votar por dos finales
nelson rico las ideas de cambio que
tiene para colombia y nos llenan de
expectativas y de mucha alegría él es
una persona que en realidad si piensa en
lo que se debe cambiar en colombia bueno
porque no el otro candidato que fue lo
que es lo que los lleva a votar por él y
no por el otro candidato por su mala
administración es cuándo
fue alcalde de bogotá fue un pésimo
administrador
usted le tocó rodolfo hernández como
presi como alcalde de esta ciudad de
bucaramanga que recuerda usted de lo que
él vivió de lo que él hizo como alcalde
sanear la economía del municipio y dejar
un superávit de 27 mil millones de pesos
en las arcas de la alcaldía
claro yo sé cómo ve eso que pueda
replicarse eventualmente en un país como
colombia con tantas con tantas cosas
tantos problemas económicos que es muy
difícil porque la persona que lo rodea
todo el mundo está salpicada de
corrupción pero se hace bien intentó
irse y se sabe que lo hace lo intentar
el una de sus principales banderas es
justamente la lucha contra la corrupción
pero sabemos que él también está
imputado por un caso de corrupción qué
opina usted de esto y cómo puede
eventualmente esto no servirle para su
candidatura no todo en su momento que en
su momento él tuvo sus investigaciones y
todo lo cual serán aclarado todos los
problemas y él lo demostró siendo
alcalde y lo que había ahorita es una
campaña de desinformación de todas las
cosas buenas que le ha hecho a usted
muchas gracias pues entonces seguiremos
muy pendientes de lo que ocurre en esta
ciudad hay que decir que el departamento
de santander fue el departamento que más
votó en la primera vuelta en donde
rodolfo hernández por supuesto ganó en
esta zona en la que el mando tuvo su
alcaldía en el período entre 2016 y 2019
un mandato que tuvo que ser suspendido
incluso antes de que lo tuviera que
entregar por diversas suspensiones que
tuvo como mandatario
daniela blandón desde la ciudad de
bucaramanga bastión de rodolfo hernández
uno de los candidatos de esta segunda
vuelta de las elecciones en colombia
cambiamos de tema quedan pocas horas
para que se cierren las urnas en la
segunda vuelta de los comicios
legislativos en francia en el país se
renuevan los 577 diputados de la
asamblea nacional y según el más
reciente informe de participación del
ministerio del interior- la
participación a las 5 de la tarde era de
un 38,11 por ciento esto es poco más de
un punto porcentual por debajo al regalo
registrado en la primera vuelta a este
proceso se muestra clave para el
presidente emmanuel macrón quien viene
de ser reelegido para otros cinco años
más que buscan mantener su mayoría
absoluta en el legislativo de cara a
sacar adelante su plan de gobierno en
frente tiene a la alianza de izquierda y
ecologistas
lópez que busca ser la principal fuerza
de oposición escuchemos a algunos
electores
voto en blanco porque para mí los
candidatos se postulan para el puesto
para juegos de poder más que para servir
realmente a la gente
hace una semana teníamos una pequeña
cola esperando con impaciencia que
abriera la oficina una decena de
personas hoy sólo tenemos unas diez
personas después de un periodo de tiempo
un poco más largo desafortunadamente
tenemos la sensación de que este día
será menos participativo que la semana
anterior pero mantenemos la esperanza
vamos a ucrania porque las autoridades
rusas están lanzando una nueva ofensiva
contra la ciudad de kharkiv según
autoridades ucranianas esta urbe del
este del territorio la segunda más
grande del país se registró hoy el
ataque sobre una planta de reparación de
tanques y contaba con la artillería
entregada por aliados extranjeros las
autoridades ucranianas advierten que la
situación se complica en la zona con la
retoma de territorios por parte de las
fuerzas rusas sobre el terreno en heart
keep se encuentra nuestra enviada
especial ir en ese avión quien
previamente nos entregó más detalle
esta es una de las más de 1000 escuelas
que han sido dañadas desde el comienzo
de este conflicto es un edificio de tres
plantas no queda nada en pie como pueden
ver el panorama es desolador las paredes
están completamente estropeadas hay
restos del techo que están a punto de
caerse bancos que han quedado
completamente
calcinado también cables sueltos restos
de libros hardcore la ciudad en la que
nos encontramos sigue siendo una de las
localidades más afectadas de este
conflicto de hecho en las últimas horas
las autoridades ucranianas han informado
que las tropas rusas han lanzado una
nueva ofensiva sobre este ciudad que
recordemos es la segunda localidad más
importante de ucrania y ya había sido
asediada al comienzo de este conflicto
esto también refleja que la guerra en
ucrania está lejos de apagarse lo ha
dicho también hoy el secretario general
de la otan quien ha afirmado que este
conflicto podría durar
años efectivamente la guerra en ucrania
podría durar años es lo que afirmó el
secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenber quien resaltó la importancia
de continuar brindando apoyo
armamentístico a kiev una opinión
compartida por el primer ministro
británico boris johnson quien advirtió
de la fatiga de los ucranianos ante el
conflicto los combates se mantienen en
ese perdón y así en la provincia del
lugar y según expertos del instituto
para el estudio de la guerra las fuerzas
rusas lograrán lo que lograrán
seguramente hacerse con el control de la
urbe pero al costo de concentrar muchas
de sus fuerzas disponibles en un área
pequeña tras visitar a sus tropas en
odessa y mykolaiv el presidente vladimir
si él es quien aseguró que no le
entregara a nadie en el sur del país
visite nuestra posición de primera línea
en la región de micro life y también la
región de desa hable con nuestros
defensores militares policías guardia
nacional defensa territorial su estado
de ánimo es confiado y mirándolos a los
ojos es obvio que todos ellos no dudan
de nuestra victoria les agradecí por el
servicio por la protección de nuestro
estado agradecía a los padres de niños
tan valientes presenté premios a los
mejores presenté la orden de la estrella
dorada al héroe de ucrania al coronel
vadim jarecki comandante de la brigada
59 de infantería motorizada separada no
regalaremos el sur a nadie devolveremos
todo eso es nuestro y el mar será
ucraniano y seguro
para repsol
en el sur de asia el monzón ha provocado
importantes inundaciones y un elevado
número de víctimas según las autoridades
al menos 42 personas han muerto en india
y bangladesh como consecuencia de las
lluvias las inundaciones y los deslaves
millones de personas quedaron
abandonadas o sin hogar
las calles se han convertido en ríos en
esta ciudad de bangladesh los residentes
luchan para moverse ya que el agua les
llega a la cintura mientras que sus
casas quedaron completamente inundadas
durante varios días las lluvias
torrenciales e incesantes han estado
azotando el noreste de bangladesh el
ejército ha llegado para evacuar a los
más aislados por las inundaciones según
las autoridades más de 4 millones de
personas están atrapadas algunos
intentan huir por sí mismos arriesgando
sus vidas más al sur en la ciudad
portuaria de chittagong varios
residentes han muerto por los
deslizamientos de tierra
las fuertes lluvias también están
afectando a la vecina india en el estado
de assam el río brahmaputra uno de los
más grandes de asia han desbordado sus
diques inundando 3.000 pueblos los
servicios de emergencia están al máximo
de su capacidad
hemos rescatado y evacuado a casi 150
personas y traeremos de vuelta a otras
50 que están actualmente igualadas
en esta región el monzón provoca
regularmente inundaciones pero según los
expertos el cambio climático está
aumentando su gravedad y frecuencia
esta es la tercera vez que nos
enfrentamos a las inundaciones
esta vez la inundación ha sumergido
completamente las calles todo lo que se
reparó después de la segunda inundación
está nuevamente en ruinas
la situación sólo puede empeorar ya que
se esperan fuertes lluvias en los
próximos dos días
de vuelta a américa latina' de jugador
entra este domingo en su séptima jornada
de paro indefinido se trata de una
protesta convocada por la confederación
nacional de nacionalidades indígenas
conaie que ratificó su manifestación
pese a que este sábado entró en vigor un
estado de decepción convocado por el
presidente guillermo lazo en tres
regiones en el país hay bloqueos de vías
en 17 de las 24 provincias incluyendo la
de pichincha cuya capital es quitó con
alguien insiste con un reclamo para que
baje el precio de los combustibles su
líder leonidas iza fue víctima ayer de
un atentado contra el vehículo en el que
se desplazaba y sant ha hecho ahora un
llamado para movilizarse hasta aquí todo
mientras que este lunes un grupo de
parlamentarios va a analizar la
revocatoria del estado de excepción
convocado por el presidente lazo
[Música]
en eeuu el centro de control y
prevención de enfermedades ha
recomendado la vacunación contra el 19
los niños a partir de los 6 meses
abriendo así una campaña que podría
empezar la próxima semana
la agencia de salud estadounidense
debería dar luz verde las vacunas contra
el cubit 19 pueden ser administradas a
los niños de menos de 5 años a partir
los 6 meses la campaña de vacunación
debería empezar la semana entrante sin
vacunar a los niños pequeños representa
una oportunidad crucial contra la
hospitalización y las muertes después de
un qubit estimados padres les recomiendo
altamente vacunar a sus niños los
síntomas del cobi 19 son por lo general
menos fuertes para los niños pero según
el centro de control de enfermedades
representa la quinta causa de mortalidad
en los niños entre 1 y 4 años las
autoridades sanitarias han insistido
para que las dosis sean administradas
antes del nuevo año escolar con la
esperanza de impedir una nueva alza de
las hospitalizaciones en caso de un
recrudecimiento de la enfermedad
no sabemos lo que nos espera no sabemos
lo que va a pasar con bea 4 o 5 y las
nuevas variantes que aparezcan
pero estoy seguro de que la vacunación
será un beneficio de la vacuna fallaba
gente que ya estaba autorizada desde el
mes de octubre para los niños entre 5 y
11 años la moderna estaba por su parte y
prohibida para los menores de 17 años
debido a algunos casos raros de
inflamación cardíaca los asesores deben
reunirse la próxima semana para decidir
si levantar o no esta interdicción para
menores de 6 a 17 años
terminamos así esta emisión informativa
en france 24 quédense en nuestra
pantalla y también en france24 punto com
[Música]